- On est plus à l'aise.
On respire mieux et
- Des voyageurs qui se sentent
libres comme l'air.
Les mesures sanitaires
et les aéroports; plus besoin
de preuves de vaccination,
fin des tests de dépistages
et le port du masque
n'est plus obligatoire,
bien que recommandé.s.s.s.s.s.s.
Ma blonde a un cancer, stade 4,
ça fait qu'il faut être un peu
plus prudents.- C'est terminé.Çn
pour les gens qui s
vaccinés.
- L'application Ar
devient facultative.
Elle était obligatoire depuis
février 2021 pour enregistrer
les preuves vaccinalesgeurs et t
de nombreuses critiques
au cours des derniers mois.
ANNIE LANGEVIN, dir. générale,
Tourisme Cantons-dAN,
ça va être un grand plus.
Dans un contexte de
compétitivité mondiale,
bien, si on a le c de critè de ,
bien c'est sûr que pour
un visiteur peut-être
qu'on était moins attractif.
- À Standstead,ière canado-amér,
des commerçants attendaient
ce retour à la normale.
- C'est 40 % de notre chiffre
d'affairaméricaiaméricaiaméricae
la mobilité des Québécois,
qui traversent et qui reviennent
et qui passent chez nous.- Il ye
et de procédures. Alors,je penss
les effets maintenant.
s'essouffle au pays, le ministre
fédéral de la Santé, Jean-Yves
Duclos, n'a pas écarté l'idée
pour les voyageurs pourraient
être imposées de nouveau.
Ici Marie-Isabelle Rochon,